austin de filet mignon de souffler
richert il n'est jamais aussi bien que
dans sa cuisine à 64 ans dont 40
derrière les fourneaux
didier clément est à nouveau un chef
étoilé la conquête de ce totem a pour
lui une saveur particulière
la langoustine rôtie à la graine de
paradis on a déjà parlé de la graine de
paradis donc le paradis c'est voilà
c'est un peu les dden avec l'étoile ces
paradis c'est des étoiles après cette
nouvelle victoire le chef a déjà
d'autres défis en vue à l'horizon 2023
ça serait de récupérer cette deuxième
étoile qu'on a affiché pendant trente
ans sur le fronton du grand hôtel du
lion d'or donc ça va être
c'est un nouveau challenge pour nous
mais
on travaille dans le défi envers
n'annonce donc c'est aussi faire évoluer
la maison faire évoluer les équipes
autour de nous évoluer nous-mêmes 2019
annus horribilis le grand hôtel du lion
d'or perd son étoile
cinquante ans qu'elle brillait au dessus
de cette maison à séisme un déshonneur
l'étoile c'est vraiment une renaissance
pour nous on va fêter l'année prochaine
et 60 ans de notre famille à la tête de
la maison maintenant nous représentons
trois générations l'hôtel est là depuis
1774 c'est un des rares hôtels à être et
restaurants à être sans discontinuer un
hôtel et un restaurant depuis 1774
donc c'est vrai que l'histoire de la
région l'histoire de la gastronomie de
la région ne se conçoit pas sans un lion
d'or étoilé après ce cauchemar éveillé
le début d'une quête acharnée vers la
reconquête ya pas de recette secrète
mais je pense qu'on s'est posé les
bonnes questions sur vraiment l'époque
sur par exemple les n'a pas ce qu'il
faut les enlever oui ou non mais ça fait
partie de notre adn de notre adn donc ça
n'a aucun sens de les enlever
il faut comprendre ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur en france à l'international
et rester réactif est toujours être en
questionnement est toujours essayé de
faire avancer la maison à romorantin
l'histoire de cet établissement s'écrit
désormais à trois avec chacun sa
partition et l'étoile pour guide